[MUSIC PLAYING]
ABE HASKINS: My
name is Abe Haskins.
I'm a developer
programs engineer,
which is a very fancy,
very Googly title
to mean I make examples and
samples, and I give talks,
and I help people understand
Firebase and Google Cloud.
As I usually do, I'd like to
give some context about who
I'm talking to, because although
obviously we have rehearsed
hundreds of times,
I would still like
to tailor things to my
audience so everyone
is on the same page.
So for some context, who
knows what Firebase is?
All right, that's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
I've been working for
Firebase for like five years.
And five years
ago, I'd say that,
and no one would raise their
hand, and I'd just cry.
So this is already off to
a better start than that.
With me is Jen Person.
She's a developer advocate
on the Firebase team as well.
JEN PERSON: Hello.
ABE HASKINS: And-- yes, hello.
And we're going to be talking
about going from a workstation
to a production with serverless.
This is going to be
a pretty fast talk.
We're going to cover
a lot of ground.
And we're going
to basically cover
everything you need to be
thinking about as you're
building with serverless.
And these concepts
really are kind
of as you're
building in general,
but they're specifically
tailored to serverless.
And throughout, it'll also
be specifically tailored
to Firebase.
As I mentioned, we're
both Firebase engineers.
So all the examples and samples,
they will be Firebase related,
but the concepts here apply to
whatever you're building with.
All the systems on
Google Cloud that we'll
talk about work just
as well if you're
running on Container
Engine or Compute Engine,
but because we're
from Firebase, it's
all going to be based
around Firebase.
So our goal when
we're building--
if you're building anything,
you want to build confidently.
But this is extra true
in the serverless world,
because as we shift towards bare
metal and things that I have
control over and I can probably
physically go and touch
to serverless, where we're not
even sure how many machines
I'm running on-- we don't get
that level of granularity--
we need to build systems
where we have confidence.
So that means
confidence in the code,
confidence in making
changes to the code,
confidence in having it
out in the wild, making
sure it's running well,
confidence that if something
goes down, I will fix it-- or I
will know about it-- confidence
that someone else will
fix it, in all likelihood.
These are all things we
have to be confident about.
And this is the general
theme of this presentation.
How do we go from starting
a project to having it
in production, live, costing
us a lot of money, confidently?
And this is broken down
into six core segments.
First thing we're going
to talk about, briefly--
code.
How to make good code.
Some things about serverless
that I think a lot of people
get wrong when they're
thinking about code.
Then we're going to go into
testing and general talk
about how we think about
testing in serverless.
We'll go into
deployments and rollback,
some of the tools,
some of the things
we announced this week about
how to do deployments better,
how to fix issues when you
deploy something broken.
Because regardless of
how good your tests are,
there's still a pretty
good chance something
bad will get into
production eventually,
so we want to prepare for that.
Then we'll move on to
configuration, environments,
dealing with staging
environments and production
environments, how to think about
how your code relates to that.
Then we'll move
into monitoring, how
to keep an eye on
what's happening, how
to know if something breaks,
how to feel confident
that if something breaks,
you'll hear about it,
preferably before
your consumers do.
And then we'll move
into figuring out
how much stuff costs,
dealing with predictability
in our pricing and all of
that fun dollar-bill stuff.
So let's start with code.
Again, I'd like to get a
sense of who is in this room.
How many people consider
themselves engineers?
OK, most everyone.
How many consider themselves
JavaScript or Node engineers
first?
OK, a lot fewer.
So this is good.
Generally, when we're
talking about serverless,
we're talking about a
couple of languages.
I'd say JavaScript
specifically, because it's
one of the most popular back-end
languages for new applications.
If we're talking about classical
enterprise applications,
obviously, it doesn't have
that same penetration,
but that's all right.
In serverless,
we're almost always
talking about JavaScript.
Sometimes we're
talking about Python,
and then sometimes we're
talking about Java or Go
in some situations.
But most of the time, we're
talking about these languages
that supposedly let you iterate
quicker by being more dynamic.
That's the first thing I want
to talk about-- this idea
that these languages, like
JavaScript and Python,
allow you to iterate faster.
And this is something
that I intensely
do not believe, this
idea that when you're
building with
serverless, that you
are going to use
these languages that
are kind of flexible
and loose to build up
these great systems, because
serverless is very contained.
We get these nice little
reusable functions
and modules we can move around.
We might think that
they're maintainable
and that they can scale
with these languages that
don't work very well at scale,
and that's simply not true.
So let me give you an example.
Here's a JavaScript function.
Imagine you're a new member of
your team, a mid-level engineer
you've just hired in, and
you give them a simple task.
Write a function that says,
is a given user privileged?
And again, this is
what I was talking
about where we're saying,
this is a Firebase snippet.
This is a conversation with
the Firebase Realtime Database.
If you're not familiar,
that's OK, because remember,
most of your engineers
probably won't be.
They won't be familiar with
any given specific technology
you're using.
So in this case, if I'm trying
to write a function that
returns true or
false, this might be
something someone would write.
They'd come in, and they'd
look at your other code.
And they'd be like, all right,
this looks like the gist of it.
I'm looking up a user's role,
checking if they're an admin,
returning what the value
from the database is.
But the problem is JavaScript
has a bunch of issues here,
and JavaScript is really
not good at telling people
about this.
And when we go to
write this code,
we're already losing
confidence by not
being able to write
new code confidently
before we compile it.
Before we build it and
run it and test it,
we're already losing confidence.
And here's a bunch of things
that this function is missing.
It doesn't have a
return statement.
It's missing an
invocation on database.
Database is not a
field, it's a method.
And that string that says "val,"
it's supposed to be "value."
And of course, you say,
these are very specific.
Of course, I'd be able to tell.
If I was really familiar
with the Firebase SDK,
or if you're really
good at JavaScript,
you might have caught the return
thing, or something like that.
But you're still not going to
be in a very good situation
if you're putting someone
new onto the team.
And as you're
growing, and as you're
onboarding more and
more people, they're
going to keep hitting these
snags again and again.
And if you're an excellent
JavaScript engineer--
which I'm sure some of you are.
I'm sure some of you are
world-class JavaScript
engineers.
You might be able
to write JavaScript
that scales and works
great, but 90% of developers
won't be able to.
So we have to talk about
a different solution.
Avoiding the idea
of faster iteration
by loosely typed languages
and things like that,
we can go and move
into typed languages.
And the people who aren't
JavaScript developers, who
aren't Python developers,
they already know this.
They understand the power
that comes with a great typing
system.
And that's something that
I feel very, very strongly
about, specifically in
regards to confidence
and fast iteration.
People look at these languages
that are more verbose,
and they say, well,
I really don't
want to have to declare
what I'm returning.
I don't want to have to
script out these models that
fit my JSON strings.
But this all comes
back to bite you.
This is like a small
timesaver in the beginning
for an extremely large
expense again and again
and again, over on.
So how do we deal with this?
I'm not going to convince any
JavaScript developer or Python
developer to move
and start writing Go.
It's probably not going
to happen overnight.
But I can probably convince
them to try TypeScript.
TypeScript compiles
to JavaScript.
It works in every situation
that JavaScript works in,
but you get all these
lovely guarantees
that come with typed languages.
So here's this same function
that we showed before
with all these issues.
And every issue here--
even if it would only
take you a few minutes
to figure out every single
one of these issues,
TypeScript can catch
as you're typing.
So here's the same function
rewritten in TypeScript.
It looks basically the same.
There's async await
operators in there.
And that's modern JavaScript.
If you were running on
a new version of Node,
you'd still get that.
If you were running in
a modern enough browser,
you would get that.
But with TypeScript,
since it's compiled,
you get that for free
everywhere without having
to worry about it.
Then we add in that string
and Boolean and just say,
hey, this is what I'm
trying to return here.
This is my end goal.
And because of
that, this function
can now be smart
enough to say, wait,
you're not returning something.
Wait, you were supposed
to invoke "database."
Wait, "once" only takes the
string "value" or "childAdded"
or "childRemoved," so "val"
can never be an option.
So all those things
that may have just
taken you a couple of
minutes to figure out
have now been removed
and are immediately
resolved by TypeScript.
And this is actually
more verbose
than TypeScript needs to be.
We can save some time.
You can infer types
in some places,
but generally, I try to write it
a bit more verbosely like this.
So my point is that TypeScript
give us a confidence about what
we're doing.
And as we build up
these APIs internally,
and we build up these systems
internally, and libraries
that different
teams are importing
and different people
are using, we really
need to make good
guarantees to everyone else
that we will keep.
We want to say to people in
other teams in our company,
hey, if you use
this library, here's
the guarantee I'm making to you.
And these things are things
that TypeScript gives you.
TypeScript also gives you
something really amazing.
It gives you autocompletion.
And again, if I'm talking to
someone who wrote a lot of Java
or wrote a lot of Go, you're
like, yeah, obviously,
autocompletion is great.
And you might not realize
how horrible autocompletion
is in JavaScript and
other dynamic languages.
It is like a best guess.
And it's because
JavaScript's really hard
to statically analyze.
It's borderline
impossible to tell
what's going to be on
an object at runtime.
So figuring out how to
do good autocompletion
is basically impossible.
TypeScript, on the other
hand, is excellent.
So now we get a bunch of
the speed of JavaScript,
a bunch of the
iteration ability,
the flexibility, all the support
of all these great libraries,
plus great autocompletion
that says, hey, here's
exactly what is on
these different methods.
And this is the
actual autocompletion
from the Firebase SDK.
We ship TypeScript with--
TypeScript definitions
with all of our libraries,
along with most of
the Cloud libraries.
So instead of having to hop
to documentation and things
like that, we get great
autocompletion in our editor.
So I highly recommend writing
TypeScript in WebStorm.
Other people like VS
Code or other options.
There's a ton of
things to pick from.
But the same autocompletion
is everywhere.
It becomes very easy.
Like I said before, we're
talking about guarantees.
Because if I make a
guarantee about something,
that's a level of confidence
that I can go forward with
and I can put out
to other teams.
And I can say, hey, I
guarantee my library is
going to expose this interface.
So if you depend
on me, it is going
to match this interface
that's defined by TypeScript
that says, hey, it
has these methods,
and it returns these things.
When we're talking about taking
on dependencies-- and again,
as a JavaScript
developer, you are
incredibly prone to doing this.
We take on dependencies
all the time.
There's a reason a
node_modules folder has
like 17 billion folders in it.
It's a ridiculous
dependency tree.
Every single one
of these is a risk.
It's a security risk.
It is a risk in terms of that
library not getting updated.
It's a risk in terms
of the amount of effort
that you're going to put into
understanding that library,
only for it to change.
So I want to talk
about how TypeScript
helps us understand how to pick
what dependencies to choose.
Because we're not going
to get away not having any
dependencies.
It just doesn't work like that.
But we can improve our
situation immensely.
So imagine you're
in a situation where
you wanted to go find a
library that would print colors
to your terminal.
Like, you're like, things
are good, print them green.
Things are bad, print them red.
And you search NPM, the package
management repository for Node,
and you say, all right,
show me some colors.
And you get 3,600 packages back.
And let's pretend somehow you
filtered out the other 3,600.
You're just like, those
aren't the ones I want.
And you come down
to two that are
common libraries people use to
colorize things in a terminal.
One is called "colors"
and one is called "chalk."
If you look at the usage
of these two libraries,
colors is the winner.
More people depend on colors
than chalk, no question.
But that's not all we
have to be concerned with.
Is colors a good library
for us to use, or is chalk?
So if we hop into
the code for these
and look at the
package.json file,
you'll see a bunch of
different gibberish.
And what we're looking here
for is a TypeScript reference
of some form-- either
the word "TypeScript"
or the extension ".ts," the
word "types," or a .d.ts file.
All of these are signs
that the developer who
has created this library
hasn't only created the library
and updated it within
the last couple years
since TypeScript has
gained popularity,
but they've also
put in the effort
to make a guarantee
to you to say,
my library is going to match
this TypeScript definition
that I'm providing you.
So this is a level
of confidence,
because now we're saying,
all right, this developer
cares enough to at least
try to make me a guarantee.
And if you look all through
colors, there's no TypeScript.
There's no reference
to TypeScript.
If you look at chalk, though,
on the other hand, there is.
There's this little .d.ts file.
And if you go, and if you
had spent years of your time
hanging out in
the Node community
and talking to
developers, you would know
chalk is the preferred way.
Colors has issues like prototype
bloat and crap like that.
But chalk is nice, clean,
simple, and up to date.
So these are the types of things
that TypeScript kind of gives
you a feel for.
The people who care about
being confident and having
consistency in
what they're doing
are generally writing TypeScript
over JavaScript these days.
So that's kind of my whole
spiel about TypeScript.
That entire section was just
write with typed languages.
TypeScript's obviously great
if you're writing JavaScript,
but in general, just please
don't use dynamic languages
for this type of stuff.
It doesn't-- it's very, very,
very hard to scale well.
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Jen
to talk a bit about testing
your code as you're writing it.
JEN PERSON: Thank you.
Testing in serverless
has a lot of things
in common with testing
in other environments,
and it has some things
that are unique.
But I'd say what's
most important to start
with is, most people
are not testing enough.
And a good place to start
is just to make sure
that you're writing some tests.
There really isn't any
consistency among different
businesses, and anyone who
comes into your company,
you cannot assume that they are
going to test things the same
way that you do right now.
So a good place to start--
if you're not testing--
I'm going to pretend
I didn't hear that--
please just write some tests.
After you're done
with that, second step
is integrating those tests
into the development lifecycle.
You want to make
things as simple
as possible, so that
your developers are
going to test regardless.
The more simple and
consistent things are,
the easier it's going to
be to run those tests.
You want things to be as
automated as possible.
So you can start by
encouraging developers
to write tests by removing
some of the cost of running
those tests.
Now, what do I mean?
Again, we have an
example here that's
written in Cloud
Functions for Firebase,
but this is going to be
the same kind of thing,
no matter what your
serverless environment is.
Here I have a very
lengthy function.
And what it does is,
when a message is written
to the database, it
sends a notification
to everybody that's in
that room and lets them
know that a message was sent.
It also checks to make sure that
it doesn't send a notification
to the person who originally
wrote the message, because they
know that they wrote it.
But this is really
hard to check.
It's really hard to test
this besides just doing
a simple deploying it and
then actually writing things
to the database.
It's really not
ideal for testing.
So it's better to write
your functions like this.
So what is it that I've
changed about this?
Here I have a
top-level namespace,
and in Cloud Functions, this
enables me to trigger functions
in a couple of different ways.
Now I have the
automatic trigger,
which occurs when
that write happens,
and I have an HTTP trigger so
that I can run it manually.
I've also moved the
function's specific logic away
and added a
send_to_room function.
And you'll notice that just
has a roomId and some text,
and that enables
me to test things
without needing any
unique objects that
may be present in your
serverless environment.
So for instance,
in Cloud Functions,
you might have something
like a document snapshot,
but rather than having to
handle that unique object,
it's so much easier
if you can just
test like this using a string.
So the second part is
running your tests.
Tests simply cannot be optional.
If they are, they're
going to get stale,
and they're not going
to be run consistently.
Even if you are a
great developer,
if it's late at night and you're
trying to patch something,
there's a good chance
that at some point,
you're going to
forget, and that's
going to be the point where
there's going to be an error.
So it's a good idea
to use something
like predeploy hooks, which
are available in Cloud
Functions and other
serverless environments.
Here you have a test that
has to be run in order
to put something into
staging or into deploying.
This means that if this fails,
it will not actually go live.
And you can also run this from
your continuous integration
or continuous deployment
environment, which is great.
So even if you're not running
it from your workstation,
if you have somewhere else
that automatically runs it,
you can still run
these hooks first.
And Abe's going to
talk a little bit more
about continuous
integration, but first,
if you want to know
more about testing,
here's a couple talks
that we suggest.
"Release with Confidence--
Testing, Debugging,
and Monitoring in a
Serverless World,"
and also "GCP and the
Future of Software Testing."
So I know we just covered
a couple of really
basic examples, but again, keep
in mind that you want tests
to be simple and automatic.
All right, let's talk about
deployment and rollback.
ABE HASKINS: So imagine
you've written some code--
using TypeScript, obviously,
because I've sold you on it--
and you've written some
tests that run automatically.
You can't deploy anything
without passing these tests.
That's great.
Let's go a step further and say,
how are we deploying our code?
How are we getting our code from
our workstation to our servers?
And this is a
question that there's
a lot of different answers to.
If you've been programming
for a minute like I have,
you might think back to
the days of uploading
SFTP files, dragging your PHP
index4.php over, whatever.
But today, we have a
lot of great options
for doing things in a way that
are very autonomous-- this
is a recurring theme.
Autonomous brings
confidence-- and that
is easy to roll back when
something goes wrong.
Because one of the
biggest problems
with having a deployment
process that isn't automated
is that if something
goes wrong, you
have to go and redo
what is probably
a 5- or 10-step process at
least with the stress of knowing
something is broken
in production.
And there's generally one
person who actually understands
the script that does the
deploy, and then there's
a bunch of people who just
read the instructions.
So there's a big bus
factor involved, too.
So I want to talk about
this really cool tool called
Cloud Build.
This is our continuous
integration,
continuous deployment tool we
have as part of Google Cloud.
So if you're already hosting
all your code in Google Cloud,
like I'm sure you are,
and you're already
deploying to Google Cloud,
that I'm sure you are,
then we can use Cloud Build
to merge those two steps.
This is a really
easy-to-set-up tool.
And what you do is you go,
you make your Cloud repo,
and you say, whenever I commit
to my production branch,
or on my master branch,
or on my staging branch,
just run an arbitrary
set of commands
up in the cloud for me.
And here we have a whole log
of me deploying a server.
It says, oh, you're triggering
by pushing to master.
You can see some of the
builds failed because there
were issues in the tests.
Some of them succeeded and
actually got deployed up.
In this case, I'm pushing
to Container Registry,
so I'm actually building
a Docker container using
this tool, all on the server.
So when I'm locally
developing, I
have my own setup for
doing the development,
but I'm not actually ever
building the Docker container.
I'm not remembering
what those commands are.
That's written down
in this fancy file
called a cloudbuild.yaml.
Now, sadly, it's a
little small up here.
It's a little hard to
read, but it's basically
broken up into three steps,
just like building and deploying
a container on Google
Cloud would be.
First we build the
container, then
we push it on up to
our Container Registry,
and then we swap out our
Kubernetes deployment
to say, hey, use
this new image--
or use this new container.
And this is just
a simple format,
and this could be anything.
We could compile
our Go code in here.
We could compile our
TypeScript in here.
We could ship up Firebase
functions from here.
We have a bunch of options.
But the flexibility here is part
of the important part, right?
Because you can-- since you
can put anything in here--
you can put any
series of build steps.
You can go set permissions,
you can change stuff.
It's really important that
you put as much of your deploy
process into this nice
written-down file as possible,
because now, to
deploy to production,
all I do is push to master--
or production, whatever
branch you want.
And this is nice,
because if you already
have a good workflow for
auditing code changes, which
I'm sure you do.
Somebody goes and
adds a feature,
they have to go do a PR,
it has to be reviewed,
and then it gets merged in.
You get all of the safety of
that going into your pushes
to production.
It's just really clean.
It's really, really nice.
And when you get a build, it
automatically goes and parses
that file.
And as you can see, we
have three steps here--
building the Docker container,
pushing the Docker container,
and updating the
Kubernetes cluster.
And it says how long
these are taking.
It gives me other
metadata about the build,
shows me the logs,
all that useful stuff.
And that's super cool.
But what's really cool is
when I break something--
when something somehow
gets past my tests
and gets past all my
code, and something's
broken in production, we have
this really tiny Rebuild button
up there.
And since we have a log of every
time I've pushed to production,
we can go back and say,
all right, last week's push
worked fine.
There was clearly something
wrong in this week.
We're panicking.
Go hit the Rebuild
button from last week.
It rebuilds the image,
and, according to this,
about 3 minutes and 30
seconds later, that's
live in production again.
The current version has now been
replaced with an older version
that we knew was working.
So instead of having to
remember how to get--
revert back a week, check
out the right commit,
rerun all the deploy steps,
you just hit a button,
and we're good.
We're back into a safe spot.
And this is the
biggest benefit for me,
because everyone
does make mistakes.
And again, if you're
scaling up a team,
people are going to make
these types of mistakes.
So automating the build process
so they're not accidentally
making a mistake in that,
automating the deployment
process, making it safe
when they do make issues--
this is all a huge
gain in confidence,
because it's a safety net.
It lets us know if
something's going--
if something does
go wrong, it lets
us know we can
confidently fix it.
We have a whole talk
about this, if you're
interested in this concept.
I think this is probably my
single most important tip
in this whole talk
is use CI/CD tools.
Go look at this talk,
"From Zero to Production--
Build a Production-Ready
Deployment Pipeline
for Your Next App."
I think it's this afternoon.
It might be tomorrow.
Either way, go check it out.
This is really,
really useful stuff.
Next, we're going to talk about
dealing with configuration,
environmental variables,
staging environments,
that type of stuff.
So I'll hand it over to Jen.
JEN PERSON: Thank you.
So historically, we know
that your applications are
going to need some sort of
environmental configuration,
if it's API keys, or there might
be some sort of credentials
that you have to pass.
And these are
probably going to be
unique for your staging
and your production
versions of your application.
So it's a good idea
to use some sort
of environmental initialization.
What do you mean by that?
A lot of these are either API
keys or are stored in JSON
files, and you might usually
have a path that you're using--
/staging/whatever.json,
and maybe you have one
for production.
And then you go into
your code and you
have two different versions
where they're both pointing
to different locations.
And that's very error-prone,
and you don't also
want to commit that secret
information as well.
So for example-- again,
going back to Firebase
as an example--
we have something that you
can do in Firebase Hosting,
which is this firebase/init.js.
And this is made automatically
by the environment.
What this enables you to do
is take the same exact code
and deploy it either to your
staging or your production,
and it will just
work, because it's
using that initialization
that's created by Firebase.
So it's based on the project
in which it is located.
Now, basic initialization
isn't enough.
We're going to want to
be able to store more
data in our environment than--
it's great that Firebase
provides that for you,
but not everywhere has
all of that automatic.
Including within Firebase,
there are certain things
that aren't just automatic.
So take this as an example.
Again, we have a Cloud Function,
and it is an onCreate one,
so it's going to
be triggered when
something is written to that
particular location database.
And we need an API token
to make a request to a URL.
Notice the token says
functions.config(),
and then yourAPI.token.
functions.config() is the
environmental configuration
provided by Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
And this enables you to put
pretty much arbitrary strings
in there.
So you can have tokens,
and in this example,
you could again
have a token that's
for your production version
and use the same exact code
in both locations.
The purpose of all
these things is
to make things as simple as
possible and remove any--
make it less error prone.
So again, if you just have
that same configuration,
and then you just
add that, based
on your different versions
of your application,
you can not worry about having
different versions of your app.
I'm going pass things
back over to Abe
to talk about monitoring your
app after you've deployed it.
ABE HASKINS: All right,
so we have almost
shipped a project
completely into production.
We're very close.
We've committed it.
We've deployed it
with our CI tool.
We've loaded it up
using the initialization
from the environment, and now
we need to keep an eye on it.
And this is, again, a
part that people really
seem to start failing at,
because it's pretty tough.
There's a lot of angles
you have to come at
in order to keep an eye
on a running application.
But we make it easier with
Google Cloud, because any time
we're talking about keeping
an eye on something,
we're talking about Stackdriver.
Stackdriver is a
really powerful tool.
I don't claim to
understand all of it,
but there's a few
gains we can get just
by doing a few simple things to
keep an eye on our application
and to feel more confident when
it's running in our production
environment.
So I'm going to first talk
about enhancing logging.
We all know the lowest common
denominator for logging
out anything is just
console.log, debug.log,
system.out.printline, right?
It goes to the standard output.
Maybe we save it to a file.
That's great.
But it's actually horrible.
It's not great at
all, because as soon
as something starts
going wrong, it
becomes very difficult
to look at these logs
and gain any
insight out of them.
This becomes
especially true if you
have a multitenant
environment with a lot
of asynchronous stuff
happening, and these logs
just kind of mush together.
So if you're looking at
one issue that went wrong,
you're going to be
like, well, is this log
from a different request?
What's happening here?
So I want to talk about how
we can get that way better.
We can get a much
better situation
without any code changes.
And so if we're
logging things out
in Cloud Functions for Firebase
or many of our other serverless
offerings, you get
a log like this.
And I want to stress
that this is just
from a normal console.log
in our JavaScript.
This is not anything special.
We're not importing any SDK.
You can see we have the
actual text of our log
all the way to the right.
That text without any coloring
on it is the actual output.
And starting from the
left, we have a timestamp
that we get automatically.
We have a name.
That name is the
function that it
was invoked to cause this log.
So for example, if I thought
one of my specific endpoints
was failing a lot,
I could say, hey,
only show me logs
for this endpoint.
That's helpful.
But what's even more helpful
is these crazy numbers right
to the right.
And what that is is
the invocation ID.
So every time I hit an endpoint,
it gets its own invocation ID.
All the logs get
tagged with that.
So if I want to go and see the
lifecycle of one specific call
to one specific endpoint, I can
click on that, filter it down.
It builds up that whole
query up there automatically,
and I can see the entire
life cycle of my execution.
And we can see it here.
We start the execution,
we run some code,
we print something
out, we get a result,
and then the function ended.
It said it took
5,300 milliseconds--
about five seconds-- to run.
And that's the
entire life cycle.
So now we're not dealing
with all those logs.
We're not dealing
with a text file
that we're trying
to grep through.
It is so much cleaner to
use Stackdriver logging
to parse our logs, to slice
and dice that information.
It's a no-brainer, especially
because it's not a code change.
And again, this comes in across
all Google Cloud projects.
If you're just setting this up,
you can get a ton of benefit
from it.
But we can move beyond logging.
This type of logging
is extremely reactive.
It's like something happened,
somehow we found out about it,
and then we went and
started looking at our logs.
But we can go a
step further, and we
can get alerted when
something goes wrong.
So the same ability
for us to know--
for it to capture those
logs and throw them out--
it can also capture
stack traces,
and it can tell us about them.
So this is Stackdriver
Error Reporting.
And Stackdriver Error
Reporting is a proactive tool.
As soon as something happens--
it's watching all the time, and
as soon as something happens,
it says, hey,
there was an error.
In this case, you
can see I've had
a few errors in those
same request_cool,
fulfill_cool methods.
And if we click on
one of those, we
get a whole bunch of insight
about that specific error.
It links us to the line
of code that caused it.
It tells us how often it
happens, when it last happened.
Of course, it gives us just a
normal stack trace to debug on.
And again, no code changes here.
This is just running in
our serverless environment,
and turning this on, we
get all this benefit.
So we can set this up.
We can say, hey, send
me a text message,
hit me up on the Google
Cloud mobile app,
send it over to
PagerDuty to route
to the right person,
all these options,
as soon as something goes wrong.
So this is a great
way to say, all right,
I know if something goes
wrong, if something throws,
I will know about it.
I know I can go-- very easily go
into the individual invocation
that caused that throw.
In a few seconds, I
can get those logs.
That's super helpful.
And the combination
of those things
gives us, again,
more confidence.
But we're still not
quite there, right?
That's more proactive.
That's getting
closer to the error,
but really, we want
to catch these things
before they happen.
We want to keep an
eye on our system
and say, if anything goes
wrong or is going to go wrong,
I should know about it.
And this is where Stackdriver
Monitoring comes up.
Now, Stackdriver
Monitoring looks
a bit different than the
rest of the Cloud console--
one, because mine is
themed black, but two,
also because it is kind
of outside the console,
because it can run
against your AWS resources
and other things like that.
But you can see here we have
two specific little dropdowns
up there, one set to
Cloud Function and one
set to Execution Count.
And here is everything about
your Google Cloud setup.
It's your cloud storage data.
It has information about how
many App Engine instances
you're running, how many Compute
Engine, CPU hours you're using,
all sorts of crazy stuff.
And you can just go in here,
chart them in different ways,
build up dashboards, and do all
sorts of fun stuff like that.
You can build those big
screens where you're like,
oh, look at the colored lines.
I know what those mean.
All through this tool.
And we're just throwing this
information out for you,
and it's super, super useful.
So here we have two lines.
We have this blue line
and this pink line.
The pink line is obviously
much lower than the blue line,
and this is to be expected,
because that blue line is
the front-end function that
actually serves up content,
and the pink line
is the one that
requests it and actually builds
up the content to be served.
And there's a big difference
in the invocation count,
because there's a caching
later between them.
The pink line is
expensive and slow,
so it doesn't get
called as much.
But we can imagine a situation
where something went wrong,
where those lines
started to converge,
where our cache was failing,
where our expiry was too short,
or something like that,
and we could easily
set up a policy to alert
us if that case started
to become true.
So an example of
this is I have a cron
job that runs to deal
with this specific cache.
The daily cache cleaner job
runs about 24 times a day.
I run-- and if at any point,
the threshold for how often it's
being executed falls
below once an hour,
I want to know about it, because
that means for some reason,
something happened that
made my cron job not run.
I don't know what it was.
It might not matter,
but something happened.
Maybe the network flickered.
Maybe the job errored
out for whatever reason.
And if we look at this,
we can see there's
been a few incidents over time.
It's texted me three times and
said, hey, just so you know,
your cron job didn't run.
And again, I don't
particularly care.
The cron job will run
again the next hour,
and as long as it
resolves, that's fine.
And the great part
about Stackdriver
is that if it resolves, it'll
text me again and say, never
mind, it's all good.
So we have this situation where
now, if something goes wrong,
we can easily debug it
with Stackdriver logging.
If something new happens,
we will get alerted
through error reporting, and
before anything bad happens,
we will keep an eye on it
with Stackdriver monitoring.
This is just spewing
confidence all over the place,
because we have such
a great idea of what
our application is doing.
And if I'm not
looking at the screen,
if I'm not in the office,
I can feel really safe
that I'm looking at
this from all angles
and keeping an eye
on what's going on.
The last thing we're going
to talk about is pricing.
I'll hand over to Jen.
JEN PERSON: Thank you.
So when it comes to pricing
of serverless, what I'm really
talking about is not just
the money involved, but just
the whole cost.
What are you really buying into?
And when I think about buying
into any system, serverless
being one of those, I
think about soy sauce.
And the reason is, I watched a
video on how soy sauce is made.
And did you know it's
actually pretty basic?
It's water and salt and
soybeans and I think yeast.
I think that I could
probably do it myself.
I've been cooking for
a long time, right?
Maybe you can see where
I'm going with this.
If I want to make dinner, and
dinner includes soy sauce,
I can either spend a really
long time making soy sauce
and probably not make it that
well, or I can make dinner.
So when you're buying
into serverless,
you're basically
paying someone else
to take care of
that system for you.
So you have to ask
yourself, what is it
that you're trying to make?
What are you trying to build?
Does it really make
sense to make something
from the ground up
yourself, or does it
make sense to invest in
somebody else making it?
Because yeah, that initial cost
is going to be more expensive.
And especially when that
system might go down,
it's going to be really hard
to give up that control.
So I'm talking about cost as in
the price, but also everything
that you're buying into.
So let's talk about forecasting.
How do you know how much
you are going to be paying?
Fortunately, many of these
systems-- all Google Cloud
systems, at least-- have
some sort of calculator,
so you can figure
out how much you're
planning on spending on it.
But it has a whole
bunch of small details
in it that you might
not be familiar with.
Do you really know how many
CPU hours you're going to need?
If only there was something
that collected that information.
Yeah, so Stackdriver,
fortunately,
collects a lot of
good details for you,
and you can use these to
calculate how much you're
going to be spending.
So yes, calculators
are great, but they're
only one part of it.
You really have to know what
all those little numbers are
behind the scenes, and that's
when Stackdriver comes in
to really help you out.
Now, keep in mind
Google Cloud has
a huge variety of
different options,
and most apps will
mix and match.
Not all apps should
be serverless.
When Cloud Functions for
Firebase first came out,
I was like, this
solves every problem.
I'm going to make everything
work with Cloud Functions.
But certain things
just don't make sense
when you have a
60-second timeout,
or you can even up
it longer than that.
But some things
take a long time,
and sometimes it
makes more sense just
to have a traditional server
that's constantly running.
So rather than trying to make
everything fit into serverless,
sometimes it's going
to be more affordable
and just make more
sense to do things
on a more traditional server.
So don't forget that there's
a whole suite of tools
out there that
Google Cloud has that
may serve your different needs.
It doesn't all have
to be serverless.
And also factor in
the cost of ops.
This sort of goes back
to where I was saying
about making the soy sauce.
There's a whole lot
of people involved
in that process
behind the scenes
before I go to the
grocery store and buy it.
And if I do it
myself, I really don't
know that I'm not going to give
myself botulism or salmonella
or something.
There's all sorts of
people behind the scenes
that are ensuring that every
single product is high quality.
So when I'm buying soy
sauce in the store,
it's going to be more expensive.
And something similar can
be said of using serverless.
So you might find
that up front, it
seems like it's going to be more
expensive than spinning things
yourself, but you can
factor in the fact
that you need fewer people to be
in charge of that ops for you,
because you're basically paying
to have someone make sure
that it's working all the time.
So for more info
on managing costs--
because this is a very
important topic, of course--
we have a few different
talks for you to pick from.
"Managing Costs in GCP--
How to Structure
Your Resources,"
"Optimizing Applications
for Scalability
while Keeping Costs at
Bay," and "Monitoring
and Forecasting Your GCP Costs."
So if money is important-- which
I'm pretty sure it is to all
businesses--
I would definitely
check these out.
So let's summarize what
we talked about today.
We want to make sure that
your serverless environment is
very reliable and that
you have confidence in it.
So we talked about writing
clean, strong code using
TypeScript.
Typed languages might
be hard to swallow
for traditional JavaScript
developers, but I agree that--
having a background in Swift--
I know what their
benefits are, and I highly
recommend checking
out TypeScript.
Systematic testing
is very important.
You need your tests to
be automated, automatic,
a no-brainer, so that as
you're growing your team,
they don't have to worry
about learning your testing
technique.
It's built in, and the easier
it is to do your tests,
the more likely
they are to be run.
Instant deployment and rollback.
We talked about how
it's important to have
an environment where you
can automatically roll back
if there are errors
in your test--
or errors in your deployment.
We talked about environments
and config and setting it up
so that your secret API
keys or your configurations
are both hidden and safe and
also are not part of your code,
so that it's agnostic of
what version of your code
you're running.
We talked about trustworthy
monitoring using Stackdriver,
and also how that
blends really nicely
into predictable pricing, and
thinking about how serverless
up front can sound more
expensive, but in the end,
it might be the
better choice for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]